متقلبن غريب لا يمكنني احد ان يتوقع
خطواته صفات حملها معه لمقر شركه تويتر
وديروا تويتر الجديد يريد الفضاء فضاءا
الكترونيا يشكله تماما كما فعل مع الفضاء
الخارجي ماسك الملياردير يبحث عن الربح
لكن جنبا الى جنب مع امور عده تقلق الجميع
وغربين معلمين واليوم تحديدا وموظفين
اطالتهم مق صله الفصل الجماعي
اوله القلق قرروا انشائي مجلسا جديدا
لتنسيق المنشورات بما يوحي بتخفيف قيود
اداره المحتوى القلق هنا ان العصفور
الازرق باخبار مضلله وخطاب كراهيه وبلا
ارشادات توجيهيه قد يؤدي للعنف ودوله مثل
الولايات المتحده مثلا مقبله على انتخابات
النصفيه
وهنا بدا بعض المغردين اصلا في الخروج من
التويتر بينما ذهب البعض الاخر بتغريدات
تحمل خطابا للكراهيه من اجل تحديد قرارات
ماسك نحوها الحذف ام الابقاء بل طال الامر
ماسك بيحددته غرد بنشر رابطا لشائعه حول
الهجوم على زوج رئيسه مجلس النواب نانسي
فلوسي قبل ان يحذف التغريده
وكانت هو ابن برج نقلت ارقامنا تظهر ان
خطاب الكراهيه ارتفع في الساعات التي
عاقبت اتمام الصفقه